thank you for joining us at 11 i'm brian
loftis and i'm denise valdez local
emergency rooms are filling up once
again leaving doctors and patients
overwhelmed the surge at valley
hospitals is due in part to more people
coming in who don't need to be there
victoria saha joins us live near sunrise
hospital with a look at how doctors are
handling yet another spike
i spoke to an er doctor who says he's
busier now than he was in 2020 when
kovan 19 became a reality although we
aren't allowed inside our local
emergency rooms i spoke to a man who
gave us some insight on just how bad the
wait times are
we got there at i think two o'clock in
the afternoon and she didn't actually
go back until
midnight that's 10 hours of waiting
inside this local emergency room on new
year's eve i don't even think there were
any empty seats john carmichael's mom
has several underlying health conditions
she's fully vaccinated but tested
positive for covid her oxygen levels
were dropping which forced them to rush
to the er i was just sitting in my car
outside of the waiting room the whole
time sharing this picture of three
ambulances just waiting to unload their
patients i certainly didn't realize
covett was this bad again you know until
i saw it firsthand though nurses were
coming into the waiting room to take his
mom's vitals she didn't get a bed until
2 a.m the next day 12 hours after she
walked in dr mark jesser is an er
director at summerlin hospital he says
this is a new reality for emergency
rooms the other day when i was there
within within six minutes six patients
came in all coveted symptoms all the
hospitals are probably maybe
15 plus percent over capacity the usual
trauma and other illnesses are piling up
on top of the nearly 60 covet patients
coming in daily
another reality of coven 19 not going
anywhere anytime soon as we near two
years into this pandemic
dr jesser says if you have symptoms of
kova 19 stay home and quarantine unless
your symptoms get worse he did emphasize
although they are busier now he did say
that the omicron variant is very mild
reporting near sunrise hospital tonight
victoria saha live local now